all right guys this is it you guys let
people know if you're watching at home
twitch.tv slash Soul Calibur it's gonna
be a battle kill again IV again Marty
wolf just has to win three in this first
set and that's all state has to win two
sets of three uphill battle for sure but
we'll start in the desert and party wolf
looking to start setting up that lease
oh hey you won on the counter we call Oh
watch save just over the previous few
batches so you gotta wonder it has even
sitting comfortably here he has to be
thinking more about the match all right
big sick little stick got a whiff
completely both of them
that was a pretty convincing opening
round there I mean he just out spaced in
his weapons and without of range for
sure it's still early going into it now
I know whoever wins does it doesn't
matter but like this one
I'm just watching so much as a fan right
now that apparently I'm barely here
jumping on the pogo just trying to make
things happen gets the lethal hit does
is there enough carry on that area and
look at that that lethal hit combo able
to get the round they're stealing it
away together
god bless the ring right good stage for
that kind of stuff absolutely airs I've
gotta throw for your troubles you get
some damage the old-fashioned way Oh
your opponents for the block well guess
on we haven't my candy corns
Wow thought of grab it the right out of
the yeah snatch them challenge this time
get it to her first
Keeley's you know has massive range but
a lot of those extended range wheels
have heavy to start up so a st. be
extremely aware of his position
allister's or not the proper button for
the situation we're hitting up the big
boy dunked probably wolf always getting
the just frame on that allowing him to
be extension just pokes its gonna wait
out there sold sergeant try to stay out
of the range of that you a [ __ ] well
what at stake it's caught on the side
step two hits at the tail end of that
soul shards gonna seal the deal by
either nice able to catch him goes all
the way now all right big swing a little
swing all up on it watch your legs the
same is looking for something he wants
party left the party with our buddy wolf
to win something you know it's a fire up
his lethal his leg extend off playing
with the release timing on that low
sword nothing above the
listen to the good music sometimes
jumping out of that race and sane first
one yeah now I don't want to get too
expressive or fluctuate too much
employees because that's one game of six
that he needs to win water is too many
water is cute but that's it that's a
good thing you know Saint able to get
that win early on you know obviously he
has a long road ahead of him yes with
two sets here he's look he has to be
feeling confident specially after that
last
I can't wait till we talk to him later
man I'll be like what are we talking
about when you're sick of it
I've bent the whole thing the whole
thing the whole shebang let's see what
happens first does it get to a part of
your FSC waste off my kid into the plant
sinners it will pay all of us Wow nice
sidestep the Pikeville management for
the Hokies situation not only for the
crown but as soon as they stand up and
it is so impressive the microlight steps
to the back - come party with the quick
dogs it's just they're faking a lot of
the right and it's very hard to pinpoint
our data i download on either one of
these two men being able to be the
opposite wow he was able to get that hit
I don't be was ready for that you have
your standards like okay even then they
don't do it every single time right
there a party wolf what's up fate went
whether a big snake did cloud the little
one knew that scene will react with the
jump and just set them up I mean it's
just it's so impressive you know to get
this far but the foot to the only one
wanted to take any prize and it's
singing in the driver seat however the
party does have a sit
that's on the recognition peak sleek
little hold this counter kiss the
follow-up and this is a much different
that we saw in the opening match up
right now cardi voltage really kind of
controlling the spacing here
brink outs having something to play but
so at all they've been playing a lot of
little heavy caliber here in the middle
of the stage run up low for the attempt
wasn't quite sure you get the punishing
time but even so going from mix-up
opportunity that scene on his toe so he
never knows what's coming next however a
sidestep oh yeah we know this combo well
extended push back at this may be enough
yes
that was so dirty he could have did the
shot but it wouldn't have watched him
enough to bring him out but instead he'd
let him get back on his feet and sent
the pack yeah he knew he would try to
attempt to get up at those perfectly
plays able to get a local man
all right looking for this opportunity
read it only one yeah a lot of respect
coke gentlemen when they run and greet
that this is they usually just flying
all right I want to seem to go to the
party won't go to swing head table who
knows that st. being a bit more passive
on his entry and it's better reacting to
the learning Symphony certain good
detects where you can that same takes us
close guys trying to bait a reaction
here out of his opponent let's see what
he does here again goes to the law
option Oh Eddie gets a grab listen to
the music baby it's so st. so
unpredictable at the big subs Kim with
these grabs not going whenever gonna be
playful part of um how about a normal
girl mine doesn't do as much damage
enjoys but I catch him watch your legs
and trying to be funky they're taking a
regular punish going for this calamity
sentry against us all day and is this
enough look at those set of fans pushing
them out of ringing look at that stain
is a 10-0 red cross stick on the range
of that one of the weaker laws let's see
party will feel probably elect to change
the stage you didn't change it after the
first time and although he hasn't said
to give beat down to oh you don't want
to give seem like a free 3 oh you know
you want to try to get as much as you
can if you were to lose this set
although
let's get to it what you want - yeah you
pick asunder best with a lot why not if
you get these Eliza said you know what
besides a game ender set you get
comfortable here and if you get a win
either better and if you run it to
Wednesday you know you made the right
choice that there there's no wrong
option here from party wolf and that is
the luxury of earning yourself a spot in
the winter side of crampons pleasant
surprise or a big mistake yes
see what happens nice Oh a cheapskate
man yeah I mean I just all about that no
big deal
I stuck came up with the while rising a
little too late here's the throw protect
successfully okay second time the first
thing I'll succeed full night shots that
beautiful stuff doesn't talk like a
feint you just kind of dashed in and
sighs cupped immediately gets to throw
on the third time third time is the
charm pops out that sizable just in case
Saint was not ready for it charge it in
there's got to be blood here and it
throws guaranteed follow-up breaks the
weak wall are you will take it that
round here like a fairly decent decision
okay all these what brown in but there's
still wrong I got beat to the face poofy
on the next you have seat card follow-up
now just quick on the delayed and second
hit
scary stuff nice dog and can't get much
from that situation point the same I'm a
dumb can you get the rotation no it's
gonna take the damage and say it's the
reset damage there
careful you does have access to
see what he does with it on the big leap
ahead that's gonna be able to anything
put watch as he taps the toes brakes the
armor and now we'll find a way to wait a
sec same solvent here's the reverse
launched over the head sit down it has
to be so satisfying
yeah you only have to get solving well
not to that a compliment like everything
else is good the throws Marine decides
to use it soul charge gives her access
to bit more moves here Wow
oh my gosh is just the game oh yeah this
is a weapons demonstration if you
haven't seen IV fellas on your eyes show
you just about everything you need to
know it's out there how long until I was
doing the monologue right now party was
still very much in this two heads come
in so that we came through it yeah oh
wow okay the double case of the head and
a stab may get disrespected oh no your
vibe got you exactly well once again he
tried to whip on his own throat okay
good
hey hey level and this is gonna be an
escalation party expect exclamation mark
he was working on a perfect in that
situation but party wolf not having it
break attack not gonna take any risks
oh wait buddy who's got this under help
yeah he's working back there but a
sliver of life livings you have to be
careful that look to be awash in this
situation party was refusing to die all
right this is where it's gonna be tough
let's see how he's gonna deal with this
using sole charge out of the range it
has to eat a 50/50 palak successfully Oh
too far but get the pickup it said gonna
talk on her last hit situation if party
wolf stealing a lot don't reset not yet
I have a little bit more to talk to you
know you're trying to leave my iron man
I'll see you later
hey yeah but uh oh by the way it's a
party wolf Tara by saying goodbye does
not want to see a three oh yeah one of
those situations are like you know you
think it's over but it's not here we go
bob is the sole charge oh that was
beautiful they would have t.i it anyway
right on point
party wolf in proposition to shake
things up a bit and not just give Saint
a reset make them work for it a bit
harder pull them in and see what he does
here here we go
goes for the sole charge keep it up
there ya know get a sidestep with you 3d
book good things
do this little wall by God homes down
and that is going to be insane on the
reset 3 games to 0 the cassandra pick
didn't look crazy but it helps party
wolf with his decision-making here now
we're winners
there's no board cushion
there's no parachute his wings have been
clipped and it's now 1 it's dead even
this is the final set here of the LCQ
and bro he who said he was winning the
whole thing oh my baby ain't field
crowd screaming alpha Kelly that's what
they want to see but when you're in this
position to have them take what works
best
I mean go with your gut still have three
games witness but what say we know what
we get you look at him it's gonna be I
agree
party was taking his time let's do this
the talked about it before all of the
marbles mark man three out of five set
let's talk about it early on in the
winner's final with these guys first met
up party wolf was able to take that win
with killing yes so he's already proven
that he can in fact do it and that was
also a longer set as well but we're all
down to this one of these two players
will move on and be the champion here of
the LCQ nice gets the dunk what he needs
at the ball up here what's the mix-up it
started for party wolf there I don't
know what that was about coming in from
the same babies trying to get back in
his head
Portia's his momentum even further
because you just want three all right
you start kind of tossing there's like
oh yeah oh yeah nice gets it counter hit
follow up here spikes into the ground
the one a serious let's see what he
doesn't it all the jump the nice GI
backs off can't get in closer to this
gets a grab now what's the mix-up all
right got him on the floor party Wharf
width of response not enough to get me
killed when he can hold them out on any
of those sweeping low attacks hold my it
more like polarize is all long wiggle
states startup fantastic it's a
continuation it's almost like the round
didn't start faint so don't block wall
to see what st. was gonna do movement
wise
nothing doing no don't panic don't
punish no problem
nice able to get the kind of hit as well
finding the openings and he needs all
okay oh great yes I'll pick up on that
one keep him up against the wall just
gonna take control and slide it to those
tunnels man nothing doing one hit at a
time saying going in it's not even like
that made something you didn't want to
look for I'm going to say diet coke
oh you got hit on his entry once again
just fantastic dealing of the sole
charge there maximizes the potential
what party won't still in there it's
gonna be here for a while and then it
starts going down party will runs out of
help but in this situation it's an open
now disappear did he go for it now
he really bent it all their party was
trying to it hopes that st. did
literally anything else
yeah Pepe had press anything would have
been lights out there but man see how
he's now that has put him in a situation
where he's down on rounds here in this
opening match nice step and the lethal
hitman is the father only going for the
full charge the party will put the late
step continuation yeah okay like that
clean option there
six games to follow up here at the wall
is kind of this print right now it's
entresto opinion here we go away from it
now kicks follow-up yes oh and we're
going to a final around here match
number one and killing having full
beater stains gonna have one let's see
what happened yes insert eyes is turn
now all Waco situation all of these
little all work sweeping them up kicking
them back just kind of making them like
a bobble heads it's not gonna st. all
over the place punching bag
up-down left-right everything working in
the favor of party ones right now but as
it's been a tournament not even a game
or set with series of momentum since an
entire tournament back-to-back st. right
back in front
that was big huge counter hit now he's
gonna have to start utilizing some of
this video the thing is you know did
despair he of Killick avenues and he's
locked into that mode where he's gonna
was one of the life he's gonna do it
again let's see what he does he's gonna
wait until he has an opportunity gets a
grab this time will simply be starting
something beautiful palsy situation
kicks now my gosh see ease looking for
any situation trying to put herself in a
guaranteed situation where it would
connect boy instead while scene is
running you know chasing it down and the
sweep of go away
that's smart after they're recovered
Crouch as well so he won't be victim of
course to the critical edge but man that
was smart stuff there well at some point
you gotta fight back right you League
just continues yes right yeah that's the
killer in st. kept trying to back out
and side stuff it was sleeping
everything that party was nor doubt was
just padding on sister pressure that you
cracked and one sequence it was Kurt so
for that situation it seems like I bet I
got you let me fight back let me see if
you're ready for this swing yeah one
course more straight games right yeah
yeah one game this set and four straight
overall called out break attack mark man
see
he is insane right now he is playing out
of his mind look at this life Lee he's
working on okay keeping them there now
sergeant run away they can come to you
oh I like we're seeing there that you
base of attack as well looking to close
that out with a and look at that same is
playing comfortably here in this LCQ
looking to move on alright get to grab
again uh-huh
keeping the pressure there goes for the
mix-up on a nice attack there to counter
back party we're walking in keeping it
quick stab and just like that the
positioning going in his favor he's
gonna pop the sole charge he gets a
follow-up it's okay that's the to crazy
and that's a fantastic duck get
recognition for party wolf watch your
legs nice get the follow up as well
let's see what he does with it nice good
blocks there from save Oh wit caught him
out of the air nice and look at that
party wolf on the scoreboard tied up on
rounds right now but again this is the
last set the final said between these
two go by Wally told hey the scene is
like I know he's comfortable right he's
gonna put this away party will first lap
gladly take every lethal hit medium
that we punish watch on the fully
charged on block yeah he was able to
really catalyze that most a fifty
percent off okay finally coming down
here great with taking advantage jumping
right over you and Wow
max range or that crap however fantastic
great for party wolf comes back at it
saying not able to grab I'm guessing the
wrong way to wiggle stick gets the low
the follow up here what's gonna happen
and gets an attack and look at that
Marty wolf two rounds to one threatening
here to tie it up you have to do
something to stop you can pack that up
if he goes down to over right now still
very much alive in the driver seat when
the opportunity to knock st. a bit off
the sides because we karate you win four
straight games yeah it looks like we
can't tell you something however this
rate jump notifying that [ __ ] truck
absolutely from gonna save right now
fighting back here's the momentum shift
what's gonna happen look at the
positioning here on the stage he's gonna
have to be very careful he does not want
to get reverse ring down here very scary
and staying away not dealing with it
come and fight me in a more reasonable
area of the stage very aware of where
he's at in the stage don't be how's the
photos good deal to get the one a
seriously I feel like he's gonna be
using that a lot here off the wall
goodness now that you were gonna die for
the follow-up anyway play what and just
get a piece of concrete put a one in my
name on the win column
I wish there was a way to just go
because well this is uh this is really
scary this is scary because right now
look at look at party he is so focused
have the right read but not able to get
the hit out of it a little bit too slow
yeah he's thinking low profile enough to
evade a weights 5e to whip something big
makes it way he's able to pull a bit and
still convert all goes to the black hole
he did not wake up with those great
presence of mind their party wolf oh
here we go what's the mix-up
goes for the big low not even anymore he
just wasn't falling for it effectively
whether short or long he just has the
internal time timer that says look it's
time to stuff other than that have fun
with the campus and then finally
starting to see this because this is
what we saw earlier in the opening set
as well he was getting a lot of those
throws in you're just there and all of a
sudden you're on the ground probably try
to get a big hit there again gets it
this time oh my god posts that right
here way whipping no that was that could
have been it right there
counter to Oh a little too much parkland
wait doesn't get a big punish in that
hallway sterling for the grab this is a
punish oh he knows check the information
buddy Tommy you party warm that was
ridiculous to Brown's edge turn around
could be happening but I'm not falling
for this bait oh we seen it time and
again
yeah never over till it's over I'm gonna
keep up on the clothes on always in
losses in this situation until after
they have said I like the auto GI there
or the horizontal what party wolf not in
the race to get the follow up on they
keeping that pressure on again pushing
towards other side here you're gonna
have to be very careful how you do this
Oh breakup sex
stand up top and st. Koch on the first
punch to get out of that it wasn't quite
your turn just yet continue with the
pressure all gets the big sweep this
side nice
Jenny this time he gets the follow-up
gonna get to yes
oh and that was very very convincing
three round straight they're getting a
hard-fought three rounds Oh Oh what
party will be able to hold it like hold
on and not let ivy do Ivy things to him
it comes out of this this is uh now
putting in on party wolf if he wins this
next match he's gonna win
get that water that couples shaking a
little bit
just a little bit it's calm down a
little bit he heard you we call it that
because we cut the part of the person
again these eyes
he loses I feel like either way this
could be an important match up here in
the tournament if party wolf is able to
wit this set right here or this match
it'll be all over that's part about this
his fate is in his own nobody he doesn't
need somebody to lose form he's gotten
here on his own skill level and
determination and all those saying is
come back boy party we'll look at the
close the door on the LCQ year 2019 and
join the rest of the invitees road boys
girls going in offensively right now oh
yeah [ __ ] man man be in the air there's
a sense of urgency and party wolf has
sniffed it and hailed it caught it it
used it for earlier and check every way
he can get it into his body and on his
person he's ready does not want to give
st. any moment of advantage any kind of
momentum years oh man he is just
swinging now look insane is eating
everything ever yeah everything is
working everything is working forty wolf
going straight through it the body st.
but to arts not in fighting the party is
for the eight players looking for a
share that 250 but st. says parties
invite I will crash it if I have the
opportunity and wolf at the door with
the denial not happening one round away
from victory and closing out the LCQ is
20 wolf from accelerate gave me ain't go
straight into the soul chart to set it
off now Shane starting to take some risk
anywhere for the big sweet early are now
popping his own soul charge we're gonna
go the other way let's do happen though
he's got huge damage on it and you don't
like rabbit cause this one is off at
over 20 wolf
everything is working looking for
anything into that see II kill into the
pop off the North Hill gonna stay
conservative play is smart but same not
give it up Rick attack so oh my god the
back whips so much is going down right
now a party wolf one hit away from it
oMG I oh my god something suffering
Saint is gonna make a comeback oh my god
he got about here
the legs ain't staying not just yeah do
not count me out check do not cut me off
commentary and most of all you party
wolf don't you dare count me out lives
to see another round that was in the
same season I can't believe he was able
to pull that off but right now again st.
still in big trouble
it's gonna be the wrong way everything
works for st. I've had enough of this
whoops the throw get the punish now -
okay nice with Punisher
you want to get some extra damage see
what the mix-up is leaving nothing on
the board everything their hearts their
impact the knowledge taking advantage of
every situation give it to them here's
the wiggle state pointed off another
opportunity this is big gets the hit as
well and he got a clean hit oh my gosh
if that might be a soupy it gets walk oh
oh oh my god 41 please not like this as
well what's gonna happen everything is
going wrong here's the sole charge st.
refuse to give up 13 seconds on the
clock sole charge right back at you
what's it gonna be who wants it more you
wanted more life 21-point of my life
with these cases we coming in from party
wolf he is your winner of the Last
Chance Qualifier with Soulcalibur sinks
and the floor Invitational give me a hug
I need that and you know what there's a
celebration but uh you gotta give it up
mark man that's only the first part yeah
that is the that's one of the tough
parts but it's not maybe that the
toughest part of the night you got to
give it up those Sain getting second
place gives them the Hat yeah absolutely
clap it up for these two gentlemen man
just fire performance for everybody up
top but even though it's not over
himself obese he came here he got the
job done and party wolf man I wonder if
that body's shaking no job Nick he's
still at eat it boss
he's still gonna need it for later but
man an amazing set you gotta give it up
for everybody that came out here for our
house caliber six world Invitational
last chance qualifier but man what a
tournament and again this is just the
first half of the ninth